Alright so let's talk about the “prove it again” bias.
This happens when women are required to perform better than men
in order to be judged equally as competent.
So let's say your company is hiring for a role out of two internal candidates.
The man's being judged on what he can do in the future,
the woman on what she's done in the past.
How do you interrupt this bias?
No.1 you can prompt a comparison.
Say something like,
“can you help me understand how Sarah's five years of experience
is different from Jim’s?”
No.2 have people go back to the objective hiring criteria
and focus on what's impartial,
like years of experience or a particular degree.
You can even strengthen this habit by having people pre-commit
to the hiring criteria.
Be a bias disrupter and follow me for more leadership and inclusion tips.